we are back again
everybody
let's do it
[Music]
oops
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
[Music]
what's up everybody welcome back to
River with Griffin oh Dad new tricks
episode 243 of ripping with Griffin your
favorite podcast
so you don't know by now
I'm gonna be a dad
Rachel is 14 weeks
um and we got all the test results the
major ones everything is good baby is
healthy so I'm super excited about that
so I want to talk about it so once again
welcome back
[Music]
let's go
all right
welcome back to riffing with Griffin
everybody thanks for being here as
always I appreciate y'all uh you know
make sure you subscribe hit the
Subscribe hit the notification button
um so you know what's going on when
we're from mcgriffin is coming on and
all that kind of stuff I'm on Twitch
daily I want to build up my twitch
Channel
you know
and uh I just I've been so busy
on the extra doing the extra content but
I am doing it so I still have to do and
it's going to be for patreon if you want
to be a patreon member but you could be
a YouTube member a patreon member or a
sub you could be a um a sub on Twitch
and you'll get this extra content and
I'm gonna film it on Twitch but I still
have to do this I want to recap the
whole season of idol that was just a
nightmare
is spoiling with Griffin you know
spoiler alert episodes it's like if you
don't have time to watch
um like silo or some of these shows when
they're done I'm gonna just recap the
whole season and just go into depth and
I'll do that on my twitch which will
then be uploaded to patreon so if you
want to be a member and help me out
there if you don't want to watch shows
or you don't care about spoilers because
people always complain to me they're
always like Griffin stop spoiling shows
so I'm gonna do it on my twitch patreon
and YouTube member stuff so thanks for
that guys I appreciate your support
don't worry it is coming if you've
already joined and you're like what's
going on Griffin you know and I only
have one tier price on uh the patreon so
you know because as you know you know
big news about to be a new dad y'all new
dad okay we'll talk about that that's
basically what most of the episode is
going to be about
so here we are
made some coffee in my e-cup
um what's going on this week oh if you
are
in the California area Orange County
Irvine Improv I will be at the Irvine
Improv this Friday just Friday night
two shows Friday night Irvine Improv so
come check me out I have the link at
Eric griffin.com or you can go to the
improv.com and you know find it there or
go to my Instagram I have a ad up there
with the links so you can check all that
stuff out there
um
yeah so what's going on uh this week uh
once again guys I made my I made my
podcast description I I used AI to help
me out today and it's just so and I just
tweaked it a little bit but it's just
great you just go into the AI and you go
all right I need a description for
today's episode I'm going to talk about
this this this and this give me one
paragraph and it gives you something and
then you could just like oh I have this
spelled wrong you could just fix it
um
I'd put Apple I didn't spell Apple TV
right yeah so I just like uh how it does
that I'm gonna I'm gonna incorporate AI
into what I do I'm gonna help it I'm
gonna use it as a tool I think we should
all use it as a tool and so like it says
today I share my personal Journey as a
new father recounting the overwhelming
mix of emotions I experienced upon
receiving the news that my baby is
healthy after 14 weeks from the initial
nervousness and fear to the overwhelming
happiness that followed I delve into the
roller coaster ride of emotions that
comes with becoming a parent
additionally I provide insightful
reviews of two shows hijacked on Apple
TV and the Lazarus Project on TNT along
with other news notes around the world I
mean that's great you know what I mean
it's just like just giving it to you
so you know I I I enjoy I'm gonna
because you know then you tweak it you
know you put your own stank on it but
it's like it gives you Janine as always
thank you so much for for that you know
um what did I do today before I get into
the comments I just want to talk about
today I went to the dentist I haven't
been to the dentist in like two years I
hate going to the dentist I hate going
to the dentist I just don't understand
why the dental the the technology is
still why are they still using a
medieval ass hook in your mouth like a
pirate I just don't understand when are
they going to come up with something
where some kind of machine you know it
goes in your mouth you bite you know
molds to your bite and then it just it
does whatever it's supposed to do
had to do a deep cleaning because I
haven't gone in two years
it was the worst you know so it's like
you're you're on your
on your back and then
it's like ice pick thing is like making
this high-pitched noise
you know it's banging on your teeth and
she had to numb my teeth and gums
because I you know it's like a deep
cleaning and and she's like raise your
left hand if you know this hurts and
it's like God damn you know
then the destruction thing in your mouth
is you know it's like oh God and this is
why you don't want to go you don't want
to go because I don't know one person
that has gone to the dentist and have
been like you know what that was dope
you know it's not like going to a
massage parlor you know or whatever you
know you're going to get some therapy or
something done and you feel good
afterwards no the ditches sucks
also there's certain etiquette too by
the way speaking of massage parlorine
the dentist and the massage parlor have
two things in have they they have one
thing in common here's what it is close
your eyes
okay
you're not supposed to be making eye
contact with your masseuse or your
dentist
that's just weird you know the dentist's
head is like right here
and imagine you you know you looking up
at your dentist just making full-on eye
contact while they in your mouth no
thank you
if I was a digit so I'd be like close
your eyes [__] you know what I mean
stop looking at me and then you know
masseuse too you're not supposed to be
you're on your back and your masseuse is
massaging your arms and stuff like that
you won't be making eye contact
especially if you're weird about it you
don't want to be look at it because you
know are you gonna be even if you're
like even if you're not being a creep
right even if you're just looking at
your masseuse nervously like what do you
do each of my arm that would be weird
too so close your eyes at the dentist
and close your eyes
at the massage parlor please
you know
DeShaun Watson
by the way I will be doing mine for all
people just listening we just a little
ASMR drinking right there I'm so sorry
people always send me messages about
that Griffin nobody wants to hear you're
disgusting drinking you know whatever
um
yeah so I will have a full review of the
NFL season that's coming up and all the
things that have been going on with that
a lot of interesting stuff going on in
the NFL also in the NBA the NBA
offseason has been pretty cool too you
know the Damian Lillard trade and uh
there's a lot of stuff to talk about at
sports I haven't talked about sports in
a while so I will get to that too all
right first up let's talk about let's
get some comments from people uh we can
also get some comments from the chat too
you know I actually could just
you know I oh wait what is this right
here see this always happens guys I
always don't know what the hell I'm
doing oh engage your audience okay so
I'm gonna do start a q a all right so I
should start doing this every episode
you know
so if you have some
question if you're in chat right now
watching live you know I will
I'll go to that too okay so let me get
back to the live chat
um anyways let's go to the comment
section thank everybody for their
comments so
musics for you 888 one day ago said can
you believe the Hulk didn't throw a
single punch in end game what a terrible
movie the first whole hour of it was
pointless well
I that's your opinion I disagree with
you uh I thought that was a really
fantastic movie I thought it was a great
ending to like 13 years of build up but
where I am in agreement with you is why
the hell wasn't the hall caulking out I
totally agree like
this oh man see now you got me all
heated because this is something I I
always thought about too and I don't
think I've ever talked about this
publicly so thank you musics for you 888
on YouTube
first of all
Thanos beat The Hulk up right
he should have his moment he never had
his moment like all everybody had their
moment Spider-Man is fighting them you
know everybody the Hulk should have had
his moment to come and you know what I
mean and have a good Thanos fight and
actually win we would have cheered it
would have been great you know but you
got him with this old you know he got
old rusty ass arm now because he was
like he did the snap you know what I
mean I just I thought they dropped the
ball on that and I'm always curious I'm
sure there's articles about it I'm sure
that the the the the the the directors
the the I'm sure those guys
have probably had well we thought about
it maybe you know they always have their
thing sometimes I think like these
people that make stuff they they too
smart for their own good you know they
just overthink things to the point where
you're just like nah man just give us
what we want
don't get me started on like you know
who does this too is video games you
guys know when I'm on Twitch I play Call
of Duty and I play Call of Duty all the
time I love that game I have a love-hate
relationship with the game first person
shooters I never played them before so
it was only in the last like three years
since the pandemic that I've been
playing I play it all the time I love it
but the people that make that game these
people they're listen they're either
trolls or idiots
trolls or idiots okay they make these
choices
in the game
that no one likes
like there's a playlist in the game
right so each week they change the
playlist so there's like different modes
you can play like solo Duos trios quads
right every week they're removing one
like who wants that
who wants that
you like when they removed the solo Maps
it infuriates me I'm sitting here I sit
down ready to play I come it's Wednesday
I'm gonna find out later today when I
get off of this and what they've done it
today too you sit down you're ready to
play the game and then solo map is gone
what are these idiots doing what are you
idiots doing
who likes that
I don't know it's like it's like they're
trolls man
only an idiot would think people like
this and I don't think these people are
idiots because they've made a fantastic
game
what it that's why I say they're trolls
they're mad that we don't like their
game
we don't like their choices I mean
that's what it is they're just mad
they're mad you know they put out a game
and they go Tada and then everybody's on
the Twitter and everything like this
sucks why would you do this and then
they're so arrogant they don't make the
changes because they're like no forget
these people you know what take away the
solo map that's what I think they're
doing
actually I have more respect for you
being sensitive about your game and
being a troll because if we find out
they're just idiots
somebody needs to be fired okay that's
all I'll say about that I didn't want to
turn this into a
um [__] Fest about Call of Duty but
believe me that another episode like
that is coming but anyway look you got
me on a tangent music thank you
um let's see what we got here
uh Tom
Tom LML I don't know how you you guys
read these dumb names Tom
lmn2036 Griffin dishing out the truth on
here all right I like that one so you
really enjoyed that episode
uh uh and then here's another here's
another troll comment they think Oh no
you're hurting my feelings I don't give
a [__] this guy the Nate show 666 not
surprised that 6666 is on the thing he
just wrote the word Target
that's kind of funny to me
you know
I know that the trolls think it's
supposed to hurt my feelings but if
Rachel wants to work at Target she will
work at Target okay and uh she's you
know what I mean so I know you think
that in your world you don't think women
should be able to make their own choices
I know in your world you trolls you
think that you know my you you're one of
these arcade guys like no woman of mine
is gonna have a job I'm sure you're oh
the people that are writing this stuff I
guarantee you are broke lonely trolls
there's no way like this guy I'm sure
lives with his mom in the basement and
he's you know he's in the basement and
he's like Mom come down here I'm about
to I'm about to tell off Eric Griffin
his wife works at Target watch this one
mom
Target send
oh yeah yeah oh I got him Mom
bring me a Hot Pocket
you know what I mean I'm sure it's that
kind of guy so but anyways you did make
me laugh because I thought that was
funny that's why I'm reading it
um this one is just rude so I'm removing
this person from my channel hide user
from Channel
that's another thing that's a great
option on YouTube guys I don't know if
you ever do if you do your own things or
put your things up there's an option
called hide user from Channel so for
them they get to write things and
they're writing and writing and they're
sending and they're like oh I got this
guy but I had this option you just hide
it so no one will ever see it but them
so in their minds they're still going
off
you know what I mean but no one you know
so it's like I'm just letting you know
you say something that that I don't like
you gone I and that's it I'll never I
don't care if you live or die you know
what I mean I'll never see you again and
I don't care so that's how you handle
that
um okay so Maverick Miller 957 wrote and
he edited it so you know he really went
in on this one question for the next pod
where was the sketchiest hotel you've
ever stayed at traveling around because
I'm in Burlington Iowa for a men's slow
pitch softball tournament and I'm a
pretty I'm pretty sure there's been 50
plus murders committed in this room
funny question you know what uh actually
I remember this hotel I stayed at I was
in my and I think I've told this many
times but whatever I was in Montana
I don't even remember what part of
Montana I was in but like when we when I
when I we pulled up me and the myself in
the other comic you know because the
other comic lived in Montana so his
family lived about 150 miles away so he
was a part of this [__] so he came
and we get to the hotel and it's called
Hotel
Motel like there's no like brand name it
just says motel and it's one of those
ones that's outside and it's snowing
it's cold and it's like two buildings so
there's an L-shaped building with the
lobby rooms first and second floor and a
separate building separated by an alley
so it looks like it's like uh uh um it
looks like it's it's shaped like a c you
know what I mean so it's like uh you
know a a square but one you know one one
side's open and it's the L is separated
by
a dark alley and then the other building
so I was I'm in that building at the end
of The Alley is a strip club and an
adult bookstore next to this
weird bar Casino
and and then I swear to God I felt like
it was a glory hole in my room you know
and it was just the seediest like you're
like oh man what's going on here and
then we just it was so bad
me and the other comic we at the end of
the show and don't even get me started
on the show at the end of the show we
got in his car and it was a snowstorm
going on and we risked it to drive back
to his parents house
you know because this hotel was so
terrible so that is a good question
thank you
um let's see
let's see somebody said uh bit stacker
wow Rachel was really funny she's very
funny
she is very funny
um let's see Megan I believe Megan Lynn
10 said I don't like video games or
sports but I love this podcast Eric just
has a way about him it's so easy to
listen and the what segment is my
favorite
it's not even really a segment so much
it's just that's how I respond to things
but thank you Megan I appreciate that
let's see uh Mr Potato Head 161.
Mr Potato Head thanks to Rick Glassman I
have a Mr Potato Head
he says I don't think Travolta was in
Face-Off either you're thinking of
Nicholas Cage I'm pretty sure Travolta
was in Face-Off right wasn't Travolta in
Face-Off didn't they change faces and
face off
you know do we need to look it up
somebody looked that up and let me know
all right anyways that's all the
comments for today a lot of great
comments thank you very much oh and then
to all the super chats guys I appreciate
that that's going all towards diapers
all the super chats from the podcast are
going towards baby stuff so Janine thank
you Bryce uh Hebert and salty J thank
you so much
um and then let's see here let me look
and see if anybody has put anything on
the questions
fan funding that's very nice of you guys
I appreciate it oh what's this right
here what is this show oh yeah yeah
that's great I love that I could see it
like that thank you very much guys
um
let's see well nobody's really uh oh are
these the questions oh so let me just go
to these let me just I'm just going to
go to some of these comments because
this is like in the mood that I'm in and
then I'll start talking about stuff
Griff I've been uh so that's Bryce
Griffin been a fan since we're College
congrats on the baby thank you so much
um so let's see then
s Rose 40 what is the best podcast
you've been a guest on best oh man
that's tough one I you know it's like I
don't know what the best one is but like
I enjoy doing Rogan that was fun but
um it's probably tiger belly just every
time I've been on tigerbelly there's
something about when Bobby and I get
together that that's always fun so that
that's a good one and then bad friends
too because then it's Andrew and Bobby
and they're both those guys I love those
guys uh Amy hey oh not Amy but a m l got
any baby names uh Rachel doesn't want me
to talk about baby names all right uh K
loud 17 will you will you teach baby
gaming will you teach baby gaming maybe
JB when can you stream Warzone with
Steve you know what he keeps asking me
to play but Steve plays really late at
night so I don't know if we're gonna be
able to do that necessarily on stream
anymore
um Alfred Wayne No dwarves in Snow White
right move or wrong move
um yeah I don't know I mean it's crazy
you know it's like that you know that's
just some like sensitivity thing that
people are like you know I I don't know
I think I I just think it's a sign of
the times move okay let me see what else
we got here
Mindy I'm so happy for you and your wife
oh I like this so I have to do this more
often every week okay but I'm not gonna
read all these
um anyways all right anyways thank you
for those questions guys I appreciate
that if you have some more you could put
them on there
all right let's get to
let's get to it you know let us get to
it
okay
um
so as you know guys
look at that ah
so I'm having a baby you know
and how do I feel about it you know so
you know I've known I've talked about it
on the podcast and I've just been kind
of like the you know the journey that
you go through is is so incredible
emotionally you know
because
you know you find out you know you got
to pee stick and your wife or your girl
whatever your situation is and they're
like you know I'm pregnant and initially
you're like oh my God because in your
mind when they pee on that stick you
think well we're having a baby because
that's how it is in the movies you know
what I mean in the movies they pee on a
stick and then like 10 minutes later
they're in the hospital giving birth and
then a four month year old baby is
handed to them
then you know that's how the movie goes
and that and that pretty much
I realize that all our knowledge about
babies comes from television and movies
our whole life you know until you get
into it yourself or unless you've been a
part of it you know
so I
you know so you find out you know and
then it's like you know Rachel is like
sick as hell you know and I you know to
the point where it's like you know we
get to six weeks and she's like
need to go to the doctor you know
because you don't know you know what I
mean so you know we uh we drive to the
doctor and she's like I mean I had to
park the car and she's sitting there
sick we can't even go into the doctor
because she's got a vomit bag and she's
just like oh my God and so then we go in
you know we see a doctor and the
doctor's like you know they do the first
they do the ultrasound you know and I
was sitting in there and I'm looking at
the the Monitor and I'm like oh wow and
uh you know then they go well here's
your baby's heartbeat
and that was like I was like oh wow like
that this real you know you hear that
heartbeat and you think well this is it
we're moving forward and then you know
then the doctor tells you like well you
know you gotta this is a great milestone
and then you know let's uh you know
let's let's go to the next one and so
hearing the way the doctor was talking
about it I was like oh so there's more
like this could not happen still you
know and so that was the first time that
I had to like compartmentalize my
feelings
and just kind of like be like okay well
let me just temper my excitement because
there's obviously things that happen you
know and so sure enough you know so we
go back in like eight weeks you know and
then like you know it was like eight
yeah it was like eight weeks and then
the doc the you know the ultrasound
ladies like she's doing her thing and
then moving it around like look look and
they go well good news your baby has
arms and legs
and like what I heard was
so there are people that there are
babies that have no arms and legs you
know what I mean I was like oh wow and
that just made me more like okay we are
not gonna get super excited at all not
yet you know
you know then we get you know we go to
I believe we went to another appointment
oh we were waiting for this appointment
now you know
and then the doctor we're talking to the
doctor and the doctor's like you know
oh no no we went to another appointment
yes yes like like two or three weeks
later we went to another appointment
and that's like 10 weeks or so and the
doctors like
they're measuring and all this and
they're like everything looks good you
know uh you know this is like you know
and we're like I'm like okay relief but
then they still had that thing in their
head but uh you know the next one is the
one you know and I'm like oh my God can
I get excited yet you know what I mean
can I can can a [__] get excited
about his baby no not yet
and this is why they tell you not to
tell anyone
and I now I know usually you go you get
a pee stick and you want to go oh my God
she's pregnant everybody knows you're
telling about it no you have to wait
because you just don't know there could
be something all along the way
this is the appointment
so on this appointment they check some
for something about the bridge of the
nose that's how they check for like down
syndrome and
other things like that and then they
check the spine for a bunch of other
abnormal abnormalities and all this kind
of stuff you know
and so I honestly was super nervous
about this because then you got to make
a choice you're like what are you gonna
do you know what I mean and everybody
makes everybody has their own personal
choice what they want to do but um
honestly this is something that like
people just don't talk about you know
they don't talk about miscarriages and
they don't talk about this moment in the
pregnancy it's the kind of thing that
people just kind of want to be like eh
let's not talk about this you know
um
but this is like what happens I realize
now it's like people wait till they get
past this and then they go we're
pregnant you know because what they're
really saying is we're keeping it you
know what I mean that's really what
they're saying and now they're letting
everybody know
so
and so you know the baby and then they
she took this great 3D image you know
what I mean and I was overwhelmed with
emotions like look at that
look at look at this little guy uh you
know it's a boy you know and he's like
you know give me give me Pam
[Laughter]
had his little arms up like I'm healthy
you know and she was like look at the
tongue and the tongue was moving and and
you know it's like the arms you see the
other pictures zooming in on the the the
hands and I just I just was like
overwhelmed with emotions like it it it
really became real for me
in that moment
and you know then I just start to think
about everything you know
Rachel went and bought a onesie and the
day before so before this appointment I
was like hey we can we just not buy
stuff yet can we just chill you know and
then
and then
um
that when we got home I wanted to see
the onesie you know I was like what does
he do one thing oh my God
you know and I'm just kind of like now
I'm like really like and I have a lot of
feelings man I'm I'm scared you know I
don't know if it's you know you're
scared because you're like oh you have
to be responsible for this life you know
I'm nervous because
same reasons you know and then I'm
thinking about things like oh my God I I
gotta get in shape you know I'm like my
God I have to make sure I stay alive
I need another I got at least be 30. can
I can I last another 30 years well
that's going to be on me you know I want
to see my my kid graduate or go on to do
things and it's just like
you know what I mean you really start to
like hone in on like what does it mean
to be a father you know like
oh my God I hate this is crazy because
I'm doing this live because I feel
myself getting very emotional right now
so bear with me
you know what I mean so I've never I
never knew my dad you know
I've
I
don't even know what it means
you know
what does it mean to be a father
I don't know
so
you know
I'm just gonna
see what you mother oh my God I'm just
gonna try to do the best I can
um
and you know you get excited you get
nervous
and that's what I'm thinking about
like I think about like how did it
affect me like you know it's like you
you go to therapy
like in therapy it came up you know my
therapist great dude you know
if anybody needs a life coach therapist
in the LA area
reach out to me I'll set you up with
this guy but anyways
he um was talking about like well you
know you have abandonment issues
and you know through my whole life I've
been like oh this isn't gonna bug me it
hasn't bugged me you know it's like I
never knew my my dad I never knew him I
don't even know I don't even know his
name so I tell you the truth my mom told
me one time and I never really it never
stuck in my head for some whatever
reason you know now my mom has dementia
and it's like I know I can ask her about
it but I don't know what she's gonna say
or do I don't even know if I want to
know but maybe I want to know now
because of this but
you know
and so my whole life I've very much been
like well you know I never knew so it's
like whatever but then he started
talking to me about like well you know
abandonment issues you know that could
be a thing you know that you you feel
abandoned by your father and it has
affected you in this this way and maybe
that's why you're feeling the way you're
feeling and I just was like man I was
like
mind-blowing you know what I mean
and so then I was like okay so it's like
that's part of it it's like just being
there showing up you know
you know what I've been
you know it is
all the people
that are in my life that have like hit
me up and been like well you know you've
been like a dad to me
you know all the people that have like
you know who I've been in their life and
they've been like well you know you're
the person I go to and you know I just
think to myself oh man so maybe I do
have
sorry a little emotional I do have you
know experience
being a parental figure in people's
lives and so it's like I'm trying to
like
come to grips uh you know
with dealing with it all but it's like
again it's just a very new fresh feeling
but I just love
this picture just really gets to me
because it's just like look at that you
know what I mean almost like the little
thumbs up like you it's we're doing it
you know and so when I saw that I just
was like whoa
so
anyways
this is where we're at guys
um
you know and I'll keep you posted along
the way you know I don't want to reveal
too many things you know what I'm saying
because Freddy chose very much like she
wants her privacy too and she said she's
actually said something to me like you
know hey you know we don't I get that I
mean you know you know I mean so I'm
what I can reveal I will what I want to
talk about I will but it's not
everything you know
um like we already have like she's got
we have names the only thing I'll say
this is what I will put out there for
for my podcast uh listeners viewers
so my name is Eric
Graham Griffin g
Eric Graham Griffin
so I've been egg you know you guys all
know this but some maybe some of you
learning this for the first time but
people you know I just the egg is my
initials it's always been my initials
and so people call me egg or whatever
when I was growing up it would be like
whatever it is you know I wanted my
podcast people to be Eggheads you know
because of that Rachel's middle name is
also G so it's like Rachel G Griffin now
so I was like telling her you know so
she's I said well I want a g name for
the middle name
because I want to continue to tradition
I just don't know any good G names
so if you guys want to if you guys have
some G names that you want to send me I
would love to hear some things because I
you know you got Gregory Gene with a G
you know there's all kinds of there's
lots of like Rachel and I have this rule
that if you come up with a name and you
laugh right after that that's it that
name's gone so like you know no matter
what it is because I said what about
ghetto it's like you know something
ghetto Griffin
see I started laughing so that means
that's a joke get out of here you know
so if you guys got some names Gideon oh
I love all these names people are saying
um see I think the same middle name
right
uh Geraldo Grant oh Grant I like a grant
oh yeah I like Grant that's actually a
good one never thought of that one Gavin
no because then I think of Gavin Newsom
yuck
listen one of my first ones I thought of
was Gandalf
whoa you know how much I want to go
Gandalf Griffin
that's the one
uh but Grant I like Grant Gray someone
else said green Gabe see these are great
put them in the chat put them in the on
your comments for me middle name ideas
that start with G so but anyway guys
thanks for being here and the support on
my journey I appreciate that as always
because you know this is what we do out
here in these streets
say goodbye to my little my little son
huh all right let's get into some other
nonsense that's going on in the world
right now oh we could talk about so this
one I thought was just this see this is
when people are trying too hard man
this is some trying too hard stuff
so there's these Xbox controllers that
blast your face with the scent of New
York za
pizza so you playing video games
and some fake Pizza smell
blasting your face what
what are we talking about
this is too much
dude I don't need to combine
smells in my video game unless it has to
do with the video game itself right if
you play in a pizza game and then maybe
it's you know this is how games are
going to get interactive where it's like
there's like you you know you're driving
a car in a video game and then there's
water splashes on the you think maybe it
starts to Spritz you with water maybe
but Pizza why
I don't know have y'all ever been to
that movie theater
have you ever been to I don't know what
it's called it's like d-zone or D
something
and you like you're sitting in the movie
thing and it um it moves
you know what I mean like it shakes and
it like you know and then like it's
spray stuff
this [__] is so terrible
I've seen a couple movies like like it's
supposed to be like let's say you're
watching Star Wars and
this you're like in the ship so the the
seat is supposedly moving with it just
don't make any sense your senses are all
messed up am I on the ship or am I
watching the ship
you know it like it's just
it's just trying too hard it's trying
too hard to be something that it
shouldn't be
I mean unless you're doing like remember
when I don't know if you guys they tried
that first person movie where like the
whole movie was like Through The Eyes of
someone and you were like it didn't work
it was a disaster it was a huge failure
damn what was the name of that movie I
forgot it was some big star was in it
too and they were just trying to like
and the whole idea of it was when the
movie comes on DVD or whatever when it
comes to home it would come to your VR
glasses and so then you could watch the
movie as this like as if you were the
person it's like that technology is not
there yet
you know it's not there yet but I don't
know if when I'm playing a video game if
like I want smells coming at me yet I
don't know if I I don't know if that's
especially Pizza unless you playing like
Ninja Turtles game and like it's like oh
that's a reward ooh pizza but how good
is that fake Pizza smell gonna be
you know some artificial Pizza smell
while you playing video games like get
out of here you're trying too hard stop
nonsense
all right so I have talked a lot about
Elon Musk in this purchase of Twitter
you know
I mean I'm on record I've said it before
I'll say it again as of right now
this to me was the dumbest purchase ever
to spend that amount of money
on something that I think he could have
just made himself
take a billion hire some really great
people and take 500 million of it is
just advertise it in marketing I mean I
think that's the key
to get people to come to it he's got the
kind of money that he could buy Super
Bowl ads and he could buy Billboards all
over the country and do a media blitz
and everybody's like well let's see what
this is about and everybody joins it you
know
so he's like all right he bought this
thing as of right now it feels like a
ridiculous purchase
but now
he's done this thing where he's changed
it to X
and then you find out that the plan is
to be this like media conglomerate that
does everything you know it's like
supposedly
it's going to be from like a marketplace
where you could buy basically like
Facebook really so you could buy things
you could do banking there's goods and
services and and and it's going to be
all powered by AI which I think is going
to be very fascinating too you know
maybe the AI is going to tell some of
these troll haters like hey uh this
seems like inappropriate or do you know
this person do you have the facts why
you're TW you know maybe it'll maybe
it's gonna curb some of that but who
knows
um so
so now I'm starting to think was this
the plan all along and then like so so
maybe in five years
it'll be this thing that like
everybody's using it you know
everybody's using it like for more than
just dumb social media posts but it's
going to be used for like everything
maybe they're gonna be competing with
YouTube and Mark Facebook Marketplace
and Amazon and and Bank of America and
he's like this is what we do and then
the next thing you know the damn
company's worth 200 billion dollars and
I'm like whoa listen he's smarter than
me you know what I mean
I'm just telling you how it looks for me
right now but we will see where it is
now where it's going so this now my only
issue with it is like changing the name
you know when you cheat you know what
this reminds me of
I used to go to this Chinese restaurant
when I had a real job back in the day
you know you'd be come home you're tired
I pull into this Chinese restaurant and
I'll be like I walk in and I go yeah let
me get to orange chicken and whatever
you know and then I just it was just
kind of a routine thing you pull into it
a lot you get it you go
one day I pulled into the lot not even
paying attention I walk into the
restaurant
and it's not the restaurant went out of
business and this is a new restaurant
same location
completely new restaurant and I was like
oh
what
what now I'm like hungry so I'm like all
right what are you serving you know and
I got something turns out it was okay
you know right and I was like I I got to
know the owner and like you know I went
back because of the relationship it was
a sushi place and that actually got me
into eating sushi because I never ate
sushi before that right
but sometimes there is something about
changing the name changing the of this
of the same place the same place you go
all the time the thing that you're used
to changing it I don't know if that's it
could be good or bad
so it's like he's changing this thing to
X and it's almost like well hey all you
users that thought it was this thing
we're gonna now make it this
and we're kind of just like forced to go
you look on your phone and the app's
changed you know
um
you know what I mean
it's like
you're just like okay well what is this
how did you do I whether you want to be
here so I think that's gonna be like a
big change there I I I don't know how
that's gonna work and then now with all
these other things popping up Tick Tock
has a text thing now
um you know threads which I think is
already dead you know I actually think
that just didn't work you know who knows
you know it's like you
you know the it's like the same kind of
thing you know all the instant if you're
on Instagram already they were like well
you know you already have threads you're
like oh do I you went over to it and you
were like okay
so what's this because this looks like
Twitter you know you know you're like
okay so and then I'm doing this with all
my other family why why can't I just do
this in my story on the other one so
I don't know I think the engagement on
threads is down now and I don't know if
it's gonna be a thing that's going to
take off and now you have it on Tick
Tock too I think that like them like I
like the idea that I'm getting different
things from different places
I don't like that they're all trying to
do the same thing
to me that's killing all of them
you know it's like it's like you go to
tick tock you go whoa what's up with
these what's up with the text dudes
we're trying to this is where I learned
to do dances and chicken recipes over
over a cardi B song this isn't where I
come to like
put out my thoughts in in in words in
Word form okay this is where I go to you
know dance okay so keep it that
Twitter was where you went to say things
Twitter was where you went to like you
know put links to stories and you know
and then Instagram is where you put
pictures and remember Vine that was
videos and then you of course Instagram
took that over and so
and then now they're all kind of doing
the same thing
so it's kind of ridiculous and like
if you follow one person and but you
know I will say this sometimes you have
a following of fans on one platform
and even though we all have all the
platforms maybe you don't want to follow
a certain person on Twitter because what
you like about them you get from Tick
Tock so forth and so on so if all of
them are doing everything on their
platform now it's going to become like
well if I could do all this here I don't
need to go because I can find the same
person here and no one's doing different
content on different things like we're
all as a content creator you're posting
the same thing on all the platforms it's
not like you not like I have Tick Tock
exclusive Roofing with Griffin stuff or
here's my Instagram post like no one's
doing that everyone's just throwing it
out there because we know we're trying
to reach as many people as possible so I
think what's going to end up happening
is people are going to start making a
choice oh I could do text here too okay
then I don't even need to be on Twitter
or uh oh uh oh now I could do how about
this it's like one of the things I do
like about out this Elon Elon now he's
he there's ads you can monetize your
stuff so that's making me want to be
like well maybe I do need to buy the
verification on Twitter so I can put
like I could put the whole podcast an
hour-long podcast I can now put it on
Twitter and monetize it there so I'm
like huh if that's the case well maybe
this will this maybe that's but then now
you're talking about well do I need
YouTube
like are people going to YouTube as much
as they did before and then again then
you also have twitch
it's like when YouTube started gaming it
was like all right you try to pick one
right to me I still like twitch because
the how you interact with the fans all
the like YouTube has like the Super Chat
and all that stuff twitch has so much
more stuff that you could interact with
each other with the with the uh with
your fans so it's superior but like if
these other places start to go hey come
game over here like kick this new play
this company called kick.com they're
trying to compete with twitch and
they're offering these big streamers
millions of dollars to switch over
you know and it's like it's like like
you just gotta you just he's coming to a
point you just you just pick well I like
this and I can get everything I need
right here and all the same people that
I watch are still here that are on the
other platforms so I don't know I don't
know how the social media Wars because
that's what's happening right now it's a
social media war and who's gonna win
right
but maybe us the consumer we're winning
because we have so many options
you know we have so many options so
we'll see guys we'll see but that's my
uh take on Mr Musk
um I know you guys heard about this
story uh this uh soccer player Killian
whatever his name is he was offered a
one-year deal to play in Saudi Arabia
I mean it's crazy so Saudi Soccer Club
has reported I know I didn't say that
right right I know you guys could be in
a chat about it in the comments offer
the record-breaking package so the total
one year is 1.1 billion dollars
let me say that again
the total money involved is
1.1 billion dollars
so there's a 332 million dollar transfer
fee that has to be paid to the team
so PSG the team the soccer the French
soccer club right that's the French one
right I like that when I play FIFA video
game I use that team so they got to pay
them
it would be like it would be like if the
Lakers
had to play Cleveland
money for LeBron James to come over to
La like that so that's what that fee is
and then they're telling him and when
you get here we'll pay you
776 million dollars to play for our team
man
would you do it
tell me in the chat
and he said no I believe I believe the
guy said no
you know and
kudos to him man
it's like
how much money is enough money like how
much money
at a certain point
how much money can you actually spend
how much money do you actually need and
when does it become not about the money
and it becomes about your quality of
life
um you know trying to be the best player
ever can you do that on that team who
probably is never going to win the World
Cup or you know what I mean
it's not gonna it's not gonna be a thing
so he's like no no I want to compete
where I'm competing so I can win the
Euro championship and go to the World
Cup and represent my country and all you
know he might have all those aspirations
and in that process the dude's gonna
make half a bill anyway he's this guy is
one of the best in the world best to
ever do it he's gonna make a lot of
money so in his mind he's calculating
like ah it ain't about the money
like at a certain point it ain't about
the money like even some of these NBA
stars who are like you know now that the
salaries are at like look at Kyrie
Irving salaries are at like 30 40
million dollars a year at 30 40 million
dollars a year no matter where you go
you're like okay so what is this really
about now do I want to play in Minnesota
or do I want to play in Miami or LA or
Dallas or some of the Premier
destinations you now are in a position
to be like well I don't want to do that
I want to do this
so I know for us
like I mean me and all of you listening
and watching right now we're like give
me that 776 million dollars you know
what I'm saying that'd be like if like
Rogan or somebody was like yeah Eric I
want um I want you to come be my co-host
on my podcast and you're gonna get like
whatever millions of dollars you know
you'll be like all right okay I need a
transfer fee though
you know what I mean you think most of
us will be like yeah give me that money
so but we're not in that position so you
have to kind of like lower the value
money to like
what you make now
so even what you make now guys it's I
know most of you ain't nowhere near 776
million dollars
but even if like let's say what if a
Saudi Arabia company
came to you right now
and it was a similar company to what you
work for now and they said to you I we
will triple your salary for three years
come live in Saudi Arabia and we'll
triple your salary would you do it
like would you do it
because that's basically what they did
to this guy and maybe he's just like you
know what I'm good I don't want to live
in Saudi Arabia uh I don't want my
family in Saudi Arabia uh I don't I just
and maybe personally he has his feelings
about that and then professionally he
might be like well I want to be on a
winning team you know like what if like
like the worst team in the NBA like the
Detroit Pistons or whatever bad team
right now they might say to like what if
there's some Superstar like you know I
don't want to say LeBron James because
he like is old now but somebody like I
don't know John Morant or one of these
like mid like like mid-level age-wise I
mean maybe some kid who's like 27-28
they're a superstar and then this one
whack team is like we're gonna give you
if they could we'll give you 150 million
dollars a year
I could see that person being and
they've already made 30 million a year
for four or five years
okay that's a lot of money but maybe
they're like well but I want to win
so you know
it really
depends on
um it depends on you know you and your
personal preference and choice guys I
didn't even get to my reviews I mean
this is crazy I I was really I really
went in on this episode and I didn't get
to get to my reviews of the shows I
wanted I wanted to
um I wanted to get to
so I gotta take that out of the
description you know and now I'm gonna
get to that next week or even on my uh
extra episodes that I do
and remember guys you know I want to
thank you guys for you know watching and
stuff like that you know what I mean so
make sure you uh hit the Subscribe
button subscribe so you can get the
notifications I go live on Wednesdays I
had to go to the dentist today that's
the reason why I started late uh if you
don't follow me on Twitch I'll be on
Twitch in a little while and we'll do
that and again patreon where I'm doing
spoiler alerts and uh the you know
maybe even some more personal videos
about you know what's going on with me
but for for the most part if you like a
show that you know
you like a show that maybe you saw it
and you want to hear have an in-depth
discussion about it well that's when you
come to riffing with Griffin or maybe
it's like
maybe it's like you don't care about
spoilers you just you're never going to
watch it and you want to hear what I
have to say about it well that's what
we're going to do on
um
on that
Network on on patreon sorry because it's
almost it's time wow what an episode I
hope you guys enjoyed the episode thanks
for being here and thanks for letting me
get emotional with y'all I appreciate it
but you know what time it is now
it is time
time for the rap recap
shout out to fishy one of these fishy
beats hey
I'ma beat a new dad
and you know I'm so glad
it ain't gonna be a fan
don't call me Chad
[Music]
oh Griffin
[Applause]
oh yeah okay
man
not sure if I can
this is like stand
you're my biggest fan
[Music]
once again
everybody tell your friends
every Wednesday
[Music]
I need a big fan base
like the beehive
[Music]
thanks for being here y'all
once again on riffle Griffin
and I will see you
next week
yeah
yeah no more music so that's it